نتوجه مره اخرى الى هشام زقوت مراسل
الجزيره في قطاع غزه يعني ذكرنا في المرات
السابقه التي حدث فيها همم اطلاق صاروخ
رمزي من قطاع غزه همم متى كان ياتي الرد
الاسرائيلي رمزي ايضا
زي العابدين لا يوجد رد اسرائيلي لرمز
هناك همم عندما يجري قصف اسرائيلي اسرائيل
تستهدف اا بشكل كبير مواقع للمقاومه
الفلسطينيه غزه كما تعرف هي مناطق بالسكان
المنازل الملتصقه ببعضها البعض وحتى هذه
المواقع همم التابعه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
هي مواقع همم ربما تكون قريبه من الحدود
الحدود مع اسرائيل وبالتالي هي بعيده بعض
الشيء عن مرض الذي يحدث هذا جانبها سواء
كان رمزيا او غير رمزيه ما هو النطاق
الزمني هل يحدث في نفس الليله بعدها بليله
بعد ان تجتمع الحكومه همم كيف كانت تجري
الامور في المرات السابقه
في المرات السابقه وفي كثير من المرات
يجري الرد سريعا هناك رد سريع تقصف من
خلال الطائرات الحربيه الاسرائيليه بعض
المواقع المقام او تقوم الاليات العسكريه
الاسرائيليه القريبه من حدود قطاع غزه
والمتمرزه هناك على طول هذه الحدود بقصف
هذه المواقع ونقاط الرصد القريبه من
الحدود والتابعه للاجنحه العسكريه لفصائل
المقاومه الفلسطينيه لكن اذا وصلت الفصائل
الفلسطينيه والاجنحه العسكريه اطلاق
صواريخ بالتالي يكون هناك اجتماع للحكومه
الاسرائيليه وللكنه الاسرائيلي وبالتالي
اقرار همم اذا كان هناك توسيع للعمليه
الاسرائيليه او لا هذه كلها سيناريوهات
ربما متوقع ردا على الصواريخ لكن حتى الان
ما نشهده في قطاع غزه ويمكن للزميل للمصور
ان يرينا كيف همم كيف هي الاوضاع في
القطاع الان ربما نشهد هدوء خيرا اا في
القطاع لا يوجد اي تحركات غير مالوفه حتى
الان ربما على الحدود ربما في السماء فقط
هو ما نستمع اليه من عزيز للطائرات
واللاسيما الطائرات الاستطلاعيه التي ترصد
جميع ما يجري في قطاع غزه من همم القطاع
وكذلك هناك كانت طلعات لبعض الطائرات
الحربيه همم الاسرائيليه فوق بعض مناطق
قطاع غزه ولا سينما فوق مدينه غزه
وبالقرب من الحدود همم اذا همم كان هناك
اي رد اسرائيلي ستنفذه بالتاكيد هذه
الطائرات الحربيه وليست طائرات الاستطلاع
كما كنا نشهد في كثير من همم المرات
وبالتالي الاوضاع هي الاوضاع متوتره الحذر
يشوب قطاع غزه هناك همم محاوله ربما
لاخلاء بعض المناطق او بعض المواقع
العسكريه همم التابعه الاج العسكريه همم
ايضا همم في هكذا همم احداث تجري تجري
تجري همم الشرطه الفلسطينيه والاجهزه
الامنيه لوزاره الداخليه الفلسطينيه
عمليات اخلاء من مواقعها تخوفا من قصف
اسرائيلي يمكن ان يستهدف هذه المواقع لا
يمكن همم بالتاكيد قراءه المشهد ايه في
اسرائيل خاصه مع هذه الحكومه الاسرائيليه
همم الاكثر تطرفا نتنياه هو الكثير من
المتطرفين الوزراء المتطرفين يمكن ان يحدث
تغيير في قواعد الاشتباك او يحاول ان يغير
في قواعد الاشتباك وبالتالي لا يمكن همم
ان يتوقع ما الذي سيجري كيف سيكون رد فعل
الجيش الاسرائيلي على هذه الصواريخ
وبالتاكيد الفصائل الفلسطينيه تؤكد انها
جاهزه لحرب مفتوحه مع الاحتلال الاسرائيلي
مع الجيش الاسرائيلي لا سيما في ظل ما
يجري في الضفه الغربيه وهي ترى همم ان
تصاعد العنف الاسرائيلي في الضفه هي هو
مؤشر خطير وهمم يجب ان ترد عليه وتوقفه
همم وخاصه ان الوسطاء
ابلغوا الفصائل الفلسطينيه ان اسرائيل
ستوقف عمليتها في الجنين وهناك سعيد حثيث
من هؤلاء الوسطاء للضغط على الجانب
الاسرائيلي من اجل ايقاف عملياته في الضفه
الغربيه وعدم استفزاز الفصائل الفلسطينيه
كي لا يكون هناك رد من قطاع غزه